creating a good user experience for
customers and the teams that maintain a
chatbot agent
are both very important and so in this
episode of deconstructing chatbots
we will share seven best practices that
will tie in key pro moves you may have
seen
in our prior lessons but we'll touch
more upon now
so stay tuned
[Music]
the first step is to future proof the
names of intents
as your agent supports a greater variety
of topics
the more successful the collaboration
with others will be
by using explicit names a common
practice is to format them as your
intention
dot expected action four common examples
of these intents
are for information collection
confirmation
supplemental questions and redirecting
to live agents
let's go through each for example when
collecting information for helping a
customer to purchase shoes for their
pups
you can name your intent choose.book to
collect parameters such as color and
size
next as a user navigates through your
flows it's good to confirm and repeat
back if the information was correct or
not
or go having two intents called
confirmation.yes
and confirmation.no are useful i will
talk more about these benefits
using confirmation yes no intents in a
bit
then there are questions that customers
may have that are not core to your
purchasing flow
but you know are frequently asked let's
call these
supplementals for example customers are
more interested in sustainability and
frequently asked pugs are your products
sustainably sourced
or may have questions about their
account and as a fourth type of intent
known as redirect.support team
is meant to allow customers to eject out
of a flow
to speak to a live person next let's
talk about reusing intents and
pages via the route group functionality
by designing your agent with reusability
in mind
it helps save time answering the same
intent from anywhere
in the journey you can do this by
creating multiple intents
and putting them together in a route
group once
and just modify every page to allow for
that same group to be used
for example you can put 100 supplemental
intents
at the beginning of a flow and at the
end
during the confirmation pages to enable
users to ask questions
outside of the flow and rebought back to
the flow after getting answers
[Music]
next you can train your agent with
phrases in bulk
by uploading them this can be done by
visiting the desired intent and
clicking the upload icon to upload a csv
or txt file
[Music]
next tip is to add rephrase variations
of questions
when you have required parameters since
it will not stop
asking this question until it gets
collected and it's good to rephrase a
question
up to three times then to pass a
customer to a human
to avoid a bad user experience if the
third try doesn't help
this is a great rule of thumb by the way
that all of us have experienced at some
point
as consumers
[Music]
and for yes no questions you want to say
did i get that
right and leverage the confirmation.yes
or no intents
this brings us to the next point it's
beneficial to reduce ambiguity by
repeating back what a person heard
as it builds trust with the user ergo by
using the money symbol
and the name of the entity in the
fulfillment section which is the reply
to the customer by the agent
you can reaffirm to the customer what
was understood from them
this applies to both the extensive list
of system entities built into dialogue
flows such as color
or date for example or custom ones you
build that you do not find as a system
entity such as size
next to enable a user to erase their
past intent for example
i want red shoes oh wait never mind
you make an intent route called go back
and make
parameter asked to null
and finally it's important to be testing
your agent as frequently as possible
when building it bit by bit
to catch errors faster you can do this
by going to the test agent functionality
on the top right side
[Music]
and there you have it seven best
practices for building a robust agent
that creates a positive user experience
both for end users and those who
maintain the agent
i hope to see you in the next episode
for deconstructing chat bots
if you like this video and would like to
see more of such content
don't forget to like and subscribe as
well as to check out the
helpful links i have listed in this
video's description cheers and thank you
for watching
you